die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers in allen guten abend
geben sie uns 20 minuten für den
überblick über diesen nachrichten
dienstag christian ist hier und hat
alles wichtige von olympia mit sieben
medaillen guten abend und das sind
unsere themen klimaschutz umfassend und
mit vetorecht die grünen präsentieren
ihr sofortprogramm gegen die
erderwärmung dritte impfung in alten und
pflegeheimen sie soll besonders
gefährdete gruppen schützen es bleiben
aber noch viele fragen und sieben meter
flug zur goldmedaille
maleike ami hamburg holt den olympiasieg
im weitsprung
wir beginnen also mit dem großen thema
klimaschutz das diesen
bundestagswahlkampf mitbestimmt aus
sicht der grünen soll das auch das
übergeordnete ziel einer nächsten
bundesregierung werden die grünen planen
in einem sofortprogramm für den fall
dass sie an der regierung beteiligt sein
werden ein klimaschutz ministerium dass
ein vetorecht haben soll
andere parteien kritisieren so könne man
keine zukunft gestalten glasboden sagt
mit mehr
sie sehen sich als die klimaschutz
partei und so haben die grünen ihren
pressetermin bewusst in einem
brandenburger naturschutzgebiet gelegt
dass hier befindliche moore findet große
mengen co2
ein kernpunkt des grünen sofortprogramms
ist die forderung nach einem klimaschutz
ministerium mit weitreichenden
befugnissen und das ministerium hat dann
entsprechend auch ein vetorecht
gegenüber anderen ressorts wenn eben
gesetze nichts auf dem weg zum 15 grad
fahrt und das heißt paris kompatibel
sind außerdem wollen die grünen den
kohleausstieg auf 2.030 vorziehen die
mobilitäts wende soll beschleunigt und
auch die erneuerbaren energien deutlich
schneller ausgebaut werden
ohne windkraft werden wir nicht zur
klimaneutralität kommen und wer
klimaschutz in sonntagsreden sagt der
muss dann auch windräder bauen dafür
werden wir in den 100 ersten tagen die
weichen stellen zwei prozent der
landesfläche für windkraft zu nutzen
15 milliarden euro zusätzlich wollen die
grün investieren
die fdp lehnt die ausgaben wie auch das
gesamte konzept ab das ist letztlich
eine verbots orgel die wir schon kannten
die uns angeboten wird unser vorschlag
ist technologieoffenheit und wirkliche
marktwirtschaftliche anreize setzen dass
die industrie umgebaut wird
die afg die den menschengemachten
klimawandel anzweifelt warnt vor allem
vor weiter steigenden verbraucherpreisen
wenn sie mit ihrem auto tanken gehen da
gehen die sprit preise durch die decke
hauseigentümer mieter werden mit co2
bepreisung werden sie zur kasse gebeten
das kann sich niemand mehr leisten in
der klimaschutz wird wahrscheinlich eine
aufgabe für generationen sein
die grünen hoffen schon im wahlkampf mit
ihrem kernthema zu punkten
die kanzlerkandidaten von cdu csu und
spd waren heute nur schwingungs gebiet
unterwegs auch dort thema der
klimaschutz und die frage wie jetzt den
opfern der katastrophe zu helfen ist
thomas münten berichtet stolberg bei
aachen auch hier hat die flut gewütet
zwei kanzler kandidaten inspizieren
gemeinsam die schäden beiden ist klar
der klimawandel wird hier sichtbar und
steht ganz oben auf der aufgabenliste
kommen der regierungen dass wir klima
anpassungsmaßnahmen in großem umfang
brauchen und auch das wird viel
veränderung bedeuten und auch viele
milliarden kosten das land auf den
stattfindenden klimawandel vorzubereiten
und ihn dann zu bekämpfen
olaf scholz geht noch weiter der
klimawandel eine jahrhundertaufgabe
was der staat zusätzlich tun muss das
kann und soll er tun und deshalb ist der
bundeshaushalt auch in der finanzplanung
der nächsten jahre
ausgestattet mit dem höchsten
investitions etat den der bund jemals
hatte
ein eigenes klimaschutz ministerium
sprechen beide nicht an
einig sind sich die konkurrenten bei
milliardenschweren wiederaufbau v es ist
dann eine länder bund übergreifende
parteiübergreifende initiative in dieser
größten unwetterkatastrophe die wir ja
seit mindestens 100 jahren in dieser
region erlebt haben
wir werden das besprechen auch in gut
vorbereiten für die konferenz der
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten zusammen mit der
bundesregierung und dann auch den
notwendigen schritt gehen der dann in
einer gesetzgebung bestehen wird die das
für die nächsten jahre sichern
mindestens sechs milliarden würden für
den wiederaufbau gebraucht der fonds
soll schnellstens kommen und bleiben
unabhängig davon wer im september
gewinnt und jetzt unser nächstes thema
in der sendung der kampf gegen korona
trotz impfung erkrankt studienergebnisse
zeigen dass manche menschen und gerade
ältere ihren schutz auch schnell wieder
verlieren können die konferenz der
gesundheitsminister hat beschlossen
ihnen eine dritte impfung anzubieten und
zwar ab september für patientinnen und
patienten mit geschwächtem immunsystem
pflegebedürftige und für sehr alte
menschen
voraussetzung die zweite impfung ist
sechs monate oder länger her
wer nicht in einem heim lebt kann die
spritze von der ärztin oder dem arzt
bekommen allersberg berichtet renate
eberle war eine der ersten corona
geimpften die zweite dosis hat sie schon
im januar bekommen von einer dritten
spritze erhofft sich die 80-jährige dass
sie ihre jetzt gewonnene freiheit nicht
wieder verliert dann könnte ich auch mal
raus ja und biete irgendwo in die gegend
fahren und anschauen flächendeckende
auffrischimpfung nach sechs monaten für
unterschiedliche risikogruppen nach dem
vorsorgeprinzip
so wollen es jetzt die
gesundheitsministerinnen und minister
der länder die impfung auf keinen fall
schadet und schädlich ist aber einen
großen nutzen hat gehen wir auf nummer
sicher
damit dieser personenkreis der sehr
verletzlich ist besonders geschützt
einige immunologen halten dieses
vorgehen nach dem vorsorgeprinzip aber
nicht für sinnvoll weil nach jetziger
studienlage noch gar nicht klar sei wer
überhaupt eine auffrischung brauche und
wer nicht blutproben würden helfen das
herauszufinden
auch wie die antikörper anzahl mit dem
tatsächlichen corona schutz genau
zusammenhängt wir erstmal testen welche
menschen unter den senioren haben eine
besonders schlechte und dann gezielt
diese rechen mit einer diktatorisch zu
beschützen und das sind methoden die
sind noch relativ felix mann 30 hat aber
im gewachsen natürlich ist das schon
ziemlich viel aufwand auf jeden fall
würde man so impfstoff sparen zumal in
ärmeren ländern menschen noch auf ihre
erste impfung warten im pflegeheim in
schorndorf bleibt renate eberle gelassen
wenn nötig würde sie sich immer wieder
impfen lassen sagt sie in china gilt
schon länger eine strikte null kowitz
strategie heißt mit allen mitteln sollen
ansteckungen vermieden werden
und das hat bis jetzt offenbar auch
funktioniert seit etwa drei wochen aber
macht die delta variante probleme
offiziell geht es gerade mal um etwa 400
fälle bei etwa 1,4 milliarden einwohnern
trotzdem fährt china radikal wieder alle
maßnahmen hoch betroffene gebiete werden
abgeriegelt und ganze städte mehrfach
durchgetestet landesweit greifen die
behörden durch stefanie schöneborn
es geht wieder los die massentest der
lockdown es ist die delta variante die
china angst macht auch in peking gibt es
mittlerweile 20 infizierte auch in
peking gilt der ausnahmezustand
touristen aus risikogebieten dürfen
nicht mehr einreisen
ich bin sehr beunruhigt die delta
variante verbreitet sich so schnell und
ist sehr an
flughafen in nanjing traten die neuen
fälle auf das war am 20 juli in den
chinesischen staatsmedien zeigen sie die
hotspots warnen von meding soll sich das
virus ausgebreitet haben durch reisende
mit dem zug dem flieger dem bus jetzt
werden mehr als 400 neuinfektionen in 15
provinzen gezählt der chef des
flughafens inland ging wurde
mittlerweile entlassen die maßnahmen
seien nicht streng genug durchgesetzt
wurden wieder werden ganze stadtviertel
in china abgesperrt es geht der partei
auch darum zu beweisen dass die
radikalen maßnahmen der kroner
bekämpfung der chinesische weg der
richtige ist tägliche pressekonferenzen
mahnen die vorsorge und die kontrolle in
den wohnvierteln ist der schlüssel mit
dem i einzudämmen
das ausmaß die dauer der epidemie hängen
im großen maße von der qualität der
präventionsmaßnahmen in den gemeinden ab
in shanghai wurde ein fall am flughafen
gemeldet nun werden alle mitarbeiter
durchgetestet schon jetzt spricht ganz
china von dem größten ausbruch seit
johann anderes wichtiges thema jetzt
bezahlbares wohnen mit dem mieten deckel
hatte berlin ja versucht mit
steigerungen zu begrenzen
das ging schief den mieten deckel hat
das verfassungsgericht kassiert jetzt
wird es der berliner senat schwerer
machen miet in eigentumswohnungen
umzuwandeln und setzt dafür ein
bundesgesetz um ganz berlin wird
ausgewiesen als gebiet mit angespannten
wohnungsmarkt details von sylvia
bleßmann
immer wieder demonstrieren berliner
gegen den verkauf ihrer mietshäuser ein
großer investoren
sie befürchten steigende preise bei
umwandlung von miet in
eigentumswohnungen und verdrängung durch
eigenbedarf klagen in berlin es ist
wirklich schon fünf nach zwölf wir
brauchen dringend das verbot der
umwandlung von miet in
eigentumswohnungen haben wir in berlin
in den letzten zehn jahren schon über
150000 wohnung gehabt die umgewandelt
wurden
und das problem ist eben dass sie oft
als anlageobjekt benutzt werden die
leute werden oft rausgeworfen berlin ist
eine mieterstadt von den 1,9 millionen
wohnungen ist mittlerweile jede vierte
wohnung in einer eigentumswohnung
umgewandelt
aber in nur jeder zehnte
eigentumswohnung wohnt auch die person
der sie gehört das land berlin erklärt
nun die ganze stadt zum gebiet mit
angespanntem wohnungsmarkt stoppt die
umwandlungen mit einer verordnung ziel
ist es dass wir bezahlbaren wohnraum in
dieser stadt erhalten und den eben nicht
immer wieder durch neue umwandlung in
eigentumswohnungen sagen mir zerstört
bekommen die verordnung geht für häuser
ab drei wohnungen nur wenn zwei drittel
der mieter selbst kaufen darf noch in
eigentum umgewandelt werden
wer jetzt eine wohnung kaufen will muss
teuer investieren in einen neubau oder
in eine bereits bestehende
eigentumswohnung
das bedeutet eigentumswohnungen in
berlin wäre ein absolutes luxusgut was
sich nur noch eine ganz beschränkte
anzahl von personen leisten können
in berlin wollen oder können laut
mieterverein aktuell nur circa fünf
prozent der mieter ihre wohnung kaufen
die neue verordnung die vor umwandlung
schützt gilt zunächst für fünf jahre ins
ausland jetzt einen tag nachdem er
urplötzlich verschwunden war ist ein
regierungskritiker aus belarus tot
aufgefunden worden
er hängt in einem park in der
ukrainischen hauptstadt kiew
die polizei geht auch dem verdacht nach
dass es sich um einen als suizid
geplanten mord gehandelt haben könnte an
vitali schoss er war vor einem jahr aus
angst vor dem autoritären regime in
belarus in die ukraine geflüchtet für
begann berichtet
schrammen an nase knie und brust werden
an vitali stoffe festgestellt als seine
leiche hier in einem käfer stadtpark
aufgehängt an einen baum gefunden wird
die genauen umstände seines todes
stünden noch nicht fest so die polizei
heute nachmittag die ermittler
untersuchen verschiedene
kriminalistische szenarien lösung
selbstmord oder als selbstmord getarnt
am ort ressourcen durch seinen protest
gegen machthaber lukaschenko unter druck
geraten vliesstoff 2020 aus belarus in
der ukraine wird er zum leiter des
belarussischen hauses die organisation
hilft hunderten regime flüchtlingen und
erhält dabei wohl auch beziehungen zu
ukrainischen rechtsextremisten alle
mitarbeiter des belarussischen hauses
hätten drohungen von lukaschenko
geheimdiensten erhalten berichtet ein
kollege von vitali später larry für mich
mitte letzter woche an und bat mich nach
seiner freundin zu sehen falls ihm etwas
passieren sollte
er habe ein schlechtes gefühl eine
vorahnung tausende belarus innen und
belarussen sind seit den gefälschten
wahlen im letzten jahr geflohen
dass sie auch im exil nicht sicher sind
wird immer deutlicher
das regime ist durch nichts aufzuhalten
wenn sie an jemanden rankommen wollen
wir alle müssen wissen wie wir uns
verhalten wenn die bedrohung zu nehmen
wenn wir verfolgt werden
wen wir dann anrufen wohin wir dann
gehen können
ob belarussische geheimdienste etwas mit
dem tod von witali scharf zu tun haben
muss nun ermittelt werden
extreme hitze macht den griechen zu
schaffen
es ist die schlimmste hitzewelle seit
mehr als 30 jahren die temperaturen
steigen in einigen landesteilen immer
wieder bis auf 45 grad und auch nachts
gibt es kaum abkühlung
die stromnetze droht zu kollabieren weil
die klimaanlagen auf hochtouren laufen
dazu kommt dürre und die angst vor neuen
waldbränden annette hilsenbeck berichtet
kühlung trinken in hat ihm jetzt das
wichtigste
es sind vor allem touristen die
unterwegs sind in der flirrenden hitze
die bewohner bleiben wenn es geht zu
hause
es ist sehr heiß ich habe immer wasser
dabei und ich vermeide die
mittagsstunden und überhaupt draußen zu
sein
das ist eine tour für die menschen hier
zu arbeiten
die stadt hat gekühlte räume geöffnet
für alte und bedürftige die kein
klimatisiertes zu hause haben das
griechische stromnetz kommt derweil an
seine belastungsgrenze für heute rechnen
die energieversorger mit dem höchsten
stromverbrauch der letzten zehn jahre
weil die klimaanlagen auf hochtouren
laufen rund um die uhr
der premierminister mit einem
dramatischen appell andere elektrogeräte
auszuschalten
ich möchte allen griechinnen und
griechen versichern dass alles
menschenmögliche getan wird um die
stromversorgung des landes zu sichern
aber wir appellieren auch an die
verbraucher und sie zu helfen ihren
verbrauch in den spitzenzeiten
einzuschränken hitze sind die griechen
eigentlich gewohnt doch über so einen
langen zeitraum und so häufig das ist
auch für sie alarmierend derartige
phänomene hatten unsere klimamodelle für
die zeit nach 2040 berechnet und das ist
beunruhigend denn es zeigt uns dass wir
schon sehr viel früher die folgen des
klimawandels zu spüren bekommen
das land ist ausgedacht heute wieder ein
brand nördlich eines vorortes von athen
die flammen sind inzwischen außer
kontrolle
die siedlung wurde evakuiert
löschflugzeuge und helikopter sind im
einsatz
auch in den nächsten tagen sollen die
hohen temperaturen anhalten und auch
weiter östlich in der türkei kämpfen sie
gegen waldbrände acht menschen sind dort
offenbar bereits gestorben darunter laut
medienberichten ein deutsch türkisches
ehepaar vor allem am mittelmeer greifen
die feuer um sich zerstören ganze
landstriche und dörfer
tausende feuerwehrleute werden aus der
luft von löschflugzeugen und helikoptern
unterstützt
doch es gibt auch deutliche kritik an
der regierung dass sie nicht genug gegen
die brände
unternehmen so und jetzt schnitt in der
sendung und eins zwei drei vier fünf
sechs sieben deutsche medaillen
christina oder sieben auf einen streich
na gänsehautmomente vormittags in tokio
hellwach nerven wie aus stahl malaika me
hamburg gewinnt im spannendsten
weitsprung finale der olympischen
geschichte im letzten versuch gold die
europa- und weltmeisterin nun auch
überglücklich im olymp happy end nach
einem weitsprung krimi gold firma leica
me hamburg in einem packenden wettkampf
liegt die favoritin vor dem letzten
sprung nur auf platz drei doch dann
gelingt der nervenstarken 27-jährigen
mit dem finalen versuch der goldene 7
meter satz das ist sowohl mich
geschlagen
die hamburger siegten vor der
zweitplatzierten brittney reese usa
bronze ging an asse bruno aus nigeria
das erste weitsprung gold für
deutschland seit 21 jahren auf den punkt
topfit auch der deutsche bahnrad vierer
der frauen im vorfeld hätte kaum einer
auf dieses quartett gewettet im velodrom
von tokio rast er ist in der
mannschaftsverfolgung zu gold überragend
schnell mit weltrekord
lisa brennauer kann es kaum also die
erste medaille für einen deutschen
bahnvierer der frau da oben zu stehen
und ja einfach das zusammen zu genießen
das team es war der wahnsinn
olympiasiegerinnen weil sie zu viert
vier kilometer als einheit fahren drei
mal den weltrekord verbessern
zuletzt im finale gegen die britinnen
die sie zum schluss sogar direkt vor
sich haben und die sie sechs sekunden
hinter sich lassen
der weltrekord 404 kaum zu glauben
medaillen die vier frauen stolz und
glücklich machen
für die deutschen basketballer und
handballer sind die olympischen
medaillen träume geplatzt ebenso für die
beachvolleyballerinnen laura ludwig
margareta kozuch dennoch war der elfte
olympiatag der bisher erfolgreichste für
das deutsche team wie gehört mit
insgesamt sieben medaillen nach dem
gewinn der silbermedaille am barren
erklimmt lukas fauser die beiden räume
und jubelt ausgelassen weil er ein
cooles bild von sich haben wollte wie
der 28 jährige später verrät am letzten
tag der turner die erste und einzige
medaille für deutschland das unfassbar
geil ich bin richtig richtig froh und
happy ebenfalls silber gewinnen die
seglerinnen susann beucke und tina lutz
in der fortin einer fx klasse im
gleichen wettbewerb sichern sich kurz
danach erik heil und thomas ploeßel
bronze paul kohle auf und alisa
stuhlemmer krönen den erfolgreichen
deutschen segeltag mit bronze in der
nagra 17 klasse und schließlich noch
zwei bronze auf dem wasser für sebastian
brendel und tim hecker im
canadier-zweier hinter kuba und china
und dann gab es noch einen weltrekord
über den sehr gestaunt wird über 400
meter hürden der männer
der norweger karsten war lief als erster
mensch unter 46 sekunden und verbesserte
seine eigene bestmarke um unglaubliche
76 hundertstel auf 45,94 sekunden
auch der zweite reben den usa blieb
unter dem alten weltrekord ja und mehr
olympia-vierten 18
genau wie immer vielen dank christian
dann schauen wir noch aufs wetter da
haben wir wieder regengüsse mit blitz
und donner und alle details gleich von
osten telli ich empfehle ihnen natürlich
das heute journal mit der kollegin
marietta slomka um 21 uhr 45
von uns war es das für heute das gesamte
team sagt danke für ihr interesse gerne
das morgen machen sie sich ein sehr
angenehmer abend tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter die großwetterlage
hat sich nicht verändert und so müssen
wir weiter mit schauern rechnen und zwar
am morgen im tagesverlauf entwickeln
sich vor allem nach norden und osten hin
hier teilweise kräftige gewitter teils
im unwetter bereich und am alpenrand
kommt neuer regen auf in der nacht lässt
der regen im süden erst mal nach oder
auch im osten verschwinden die gewitter
allmählich sonst lockert es teilweise
auf im westen gibt es doch recht dichte
wolken und das bei tiefsten temperaturen
bis 11 grad an den alpen 8 grad in
schleswig holstein und 14 grad zum
beispiel an der nordsee
morgen dann am vormittag im osten erste
schauer auch richtung mitte und im
südwesten regen der verstärkt sich zum
nachmittag dann und im norden da wird es
allmählich durchwachsener mit heftigen
gewittern teils mit starkregen sturmböen
und hagel am ehesten noch etwas
sonnenschein richtung küsten bei
höchsten temperaturen von 23 grad im
osten deutschlands und 17 grad an den
alpen in den nächsten tagen gibt es
weitere schauer und gewitter vor allem
am donnerstag sehr durchwachsen 18 bis
23 grad dann wird es zaghaft wärmer und
am samstag bis 27 grad aber weitere
gewitter ein schöner abend